So, taking a look at this snippet of code,
it looks like $(document).click() is taking in some kind of function.
We see function, then a parameter, and
then these curly braces that are passing in, well, some instructions.
This is similar to regular function syntax,
where we declare a function with the keyword function, set some parameters, and
then put code inside curly braces.
But this function doesn't seem to have a name.
And that's kind of curious.
So let's go ahead and open up Google.
I typed in JavaScript function without name and
I'm going to take a look at the results.
We came across an article about JavaScript Anonymous Functions.
This seems really useful.
It looks like an anonymous function is one that's declared without a name.
That sounds like what we've got.
So it looks like $(document).click is taking an anonymous function as
a parameter.
You'll find anonymous functions all over the place in JavaScript.
So I encourage you to check out the resources in the Instructor Notes to learn
more about them.